stell dir vor du würdest morgen
aufwachen und könntest nichts mehr sehen
du schaust nie wieder auf berge er
blickt keine wälder mehr und sie ist
auch das wasser zu keinem augenblick
deines lebens je wieder alles was bleibt
sind geräusche für die meisten
unvorstellbar in unserer gesellschaft
spielt das auge eine große rolle
orientierung partnerwahl unterhaltung
durch filme und arbeiten am computer all
das geschieht visuell dieses mal möchte
ich herausfinden wie es ist seinen
alltag ohne unseren mächtigsten sind zu
bewältigen 24 stunden blind sein und
dabei ohne zu sehen zu kochen zu essen
durch die stadt zu laufen und
einzukaufen
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist 24 stunden werde ich gar nichts
sehen und du bist jetzt sehen wie
adressen sich ja wunderschön ist meine
nase ich sehe gar nichts danke an meine
bezaubernde assistenten bist du ja hätte
und sie können ihn gesetzt dass sich
hingesetzt habe so viel macht es nochmal
das wasser geben
die umfrage war
wie viel soll ich da einschränken woher
weiß ich von stop ist ich muss da rein
fassen damit ich weiß wie viele drin ist
war das genug ich glaube dass das
leichteste was ich jetzt nächsten 24
stunden machen werde
ok handy vielleicht kann man hier noch
wozu benutzen ok google schreibt sowie
eine nachricht auf what's up
vielen lieben dank für deine hilfe
also das ist schon mal eine option
gewährt nachrichten schreiben kann ich
kann aber keine anhören glaube ich wir
sind ja gerade auch ein live auftritt
und der chat darf jetzt bestimmen was
ich als nächstes probieren muss das wäre
lustig ich kann mich selbst zeichnen gut
ich bin jetzt richtig neugierig das zu
sehen dieses video ist als
gemeinschaftsprojekt mit marius
angeschrien entstanden aber er hat das
fehlen des see sind auf eine etwas
andere art und weise beleuchtet er war
24 stunden in einem dunklen raum
eingesperrt und hat dabei untersucht wie
sich der mangel an licht auf seine
psyche auswirkt dieses video ist
natürlich verlinkt ich wage mich an
meine ersten schritte durch unsere
wohnung und erkunde die welt zum ersten
mal nur mit anderen sinnen anstatt mir
mit meinen augen sofort ein bild meiner
umgebung machen zu können baut sich
dieses bild nach und nach in meinem
hinterkopf auf durch berührungen und
groben schätzungen meines gehirns
das ist ein zecken links einer
zeckenzange so jetzt wird gekocht aber
die so viel braucht das brett nicht sein
ich nehme das meister mit größter
vorsicht
[Musik]
ich hab keine lust hast ja wie rost auf
einmal ja geil kochen beste leben so
viel mal die sollen löffel holen ist
natürlich gemacht ich weiß natürlich wo
der löffel isst was habe ich getan
dass er wirklich topf da ich fast sind
halt doch gelangt ich kann das ganz gut
ohne augen dass ich spüre es ja relativ
gutgläubig ja wenn man seine augen ich
habe viel weniger angst mich zu
schneiden was sonst junge manche muss es
nicht dass die paprika ist aber nicht
barrierefrei ohne die hilfe von sophie
hätte ich es nicht geschafft zu kochen
das finden aller zutaten oder auch nur
nachzuschauen ob das essen an brennt ist
für mich beinahe unmöglich auf ihrem
kanal bringen sie ihren zuschauern das
kochen ball und das klappt irgendwie
auch bei mir sogar ohne zu schauen
aber essen ist für mich kein problem so
mehr oder weniger und jetzt spielen
sophie und ich gta das heißt sie steuert
mich ich spiel gta komplett drin ist
egal ich mache jetzt noch nicht
verstanden computerspielen ohne augen
ist für mich zwar komisch und lustig
aber wie schaffen es blinde am computer
sogar produktiv zu arbeiten
vieles verunsichert mich plötzlich bei
dinge über die ich vorher nie
nachgedacht habe finde ich mich jetzt
hilflos wieder okay google stelle einen
wecker für 7
zum ersten mal in meinem leben wache ich
auf und alles bleibt schwarz ich erwache
nicht in eine welt aus bildern sondern
in eine welt aus geräuschen berührungen
und gerüchten bevor ich heute also blind
auf die straße gehe und einkauf obwohl
ich mir hilfe und rede mit fabian sie
meistert bohne zu sehen nicht nur ihren
alltag sondern schafft es unter dem
namen y sogar youtube videos zu drehen
und zu schneiden was ist das
schwierigste an blind sein woher weißt
du es wenn du dein glas wasser
ich habe auch gemerkt ich kann richtig
gute nachrichten zu verschicken
und das klappt auch ganz gut du hast das
ganze verwundert reagiert
keine sprache benutzt aber ich tippe auf
clips also ich mach das mal den strafen
sprachassistenten aus weil es schneller
geht aber das projekt uhr die hilfe die
extrem beim pc gibt's das war so ein
luxus ist jedoch praktisch wenn es auch
handys genauso ein handy folie gegensatz
dazu würde das zu filigran ist weiß in
einer ganz kleinen tastatur auf dem
handy weißt du wo sie doch noch drauf
sind weil festnetztelefon oder sterben
wenn du zum beispiel mit karte gezeigt
irgendwo auf der 5
damit du weißt dass du fülle von davon
ausgeben komme ich zu einer anderen zeit
ich habe keinen tag wieder aussiehst
dich du bist mir direkt als extrem
energie fischvorkommen hast du den raum
betreten hat das sehr viel gedacht
direkt und als sehr freundlichen
eindruck gemacht
wie macht man das mit beziehungen das
ist natürlich egal wie jemand aussieht
aber vorwürfe ich habe auch ganz wie
jeder andere menschen beuteschema es
zählt ja auch zu aussehen so was
diktatur wie zb einer umarmung ein
händedruck sagt umfasst
es gibt noch eine sache die ich
unbedingt loswerden möchte kennst du
leitlinien
zb im hauptbahnhof die sind für blinde
menschen gemacht dass die sich daran
orientieren können einfach gerade
gegenteil
denkst du ich könnte jetzt blind
drauflos gehen und die nächste
bayerischen fabiana hatten ja noch
weitere wertvolle tipps gegeben wie ich
mich durch die welt bewegen kann und zum
beispiel den blindenstock richtig nutzen
auf mich hat sie einen sehr
selbstbewussten eindruck gemacht in
ihrer situation wir werden sehen ob das
auch für mich möglich ist ich werde
versuchen ihr brötchen zu holen und
möchte versuchen ob ich selbstständig
zum bahnhof kommen kann wo bin ich an
einer der stärksten straßen mitten in
köln
ich bekomme wieder zwei brezeln
[Musik]
vielen dank
jawohl
ja vielen dank generell die straße ok
stopp bank okay wenn sie wieder da da
ist jetzt nicht mehr die straßen ich
habe überlebt
lange dafür über die ampel zu gehen war
wirklich der horror
ich fühle mich komplett aufgeschmissen
entschädigung einmal zum hauptbahnhof
schwer weil man nicht nur prosieben geht
der theoretisch das christkind ich kann
mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen wie das
ist wenn man jetzt wirklich nicht mal
jemand hat der bayern ist und einem
hilfspolizisten einfach so ewig dann
geradeaus zu gehen ohne was zu sehen
okay die akustik ändert sich deswegen
gehe ich mal davon aus dass wir drin
sind hättest du hier irgendwas was das
aber das sind nicht diese wilden von der
sie meint ja hier geht es zu einem
ziemlich geil
heftig ich fühle mich tatsächlich jetzt
erst mal so richtig sicher einfach nicht
weiß wo diese wellen sind das ist ein
mega das gefühl dass sich die rillen hin
hallo wir sind die rhön weg wir sind
draußen also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich
hatte alleine denn gleich gefunden hätte
denn ich brauch' ich dachte bisher die
reden wäre einfach nur darum irgendwie
abwasser oder wasser wegzudiskutieren
der bahnhof ist quasi komplett gerade
oder immer wenn so ein gleis an der
seite ist hingegen nochmals auf den weg
wo man theoretisch auch mit dem stab zu
erfüllen könnte
wo ist dann eben jetzt für ein angeht
was aber ich habe sie bereit ist
bin ja so lauten ich glaube ist es zu
gefährlich als dass ich hier einfach
noch irgendwo womit kaufen würde
deswegen glaube ich gehe mal wieder in
sicheres zuhause aber nicht mit der bahn
weil ich glaube dass du echt zu
gefährlich mit der wenigen erfahrung die
ich habe sondern mit meinem taxi
während ich mich in meinen eigenen vier
wänden noch zurecht gefunden habe wäre
ich ohne meine begleitperson in der
stadt absolut hoffnungslos verloren ich
fühle mich fast immer hilflos und bin
auf andere menschen angewiesen ich
konnte in den letzten mittlerweile fast
24 stunden nur leicht an der oberfläche
kratzen von dem was es heißt ein leben
lang blind zu sein und trotzdem hat mich
vor allem der ausflug in die stadt fast
traumatisiert ich bin aber froh wie
viele neuerungen blinden mittlerweile
helfen können hilfslinien am boden fahrt
erkennungs geräte und vor allem handy
ist die texte vorlesen können und noch
so viel mehr
es ist ein hohn wenn ich meine augen auf
um ein bio vegas
hoffmann ich kann ja auch nicht mehr
aufhalten dass zwei sekunden wo man
gottes ist geil voll schön herum zu
laufen was zu sehen dass es richtig kalt
es ist auf jeden fall viel entspannter
und ich habe respekt vor jedem der sich
damit arrangieren kann
das war finde ich für mich eines der
spannendsten experimente die ich jemals
gemacht haben ich hoffe dass wir
vielleicht davon etwas mitnimmt und in
zukunft blind menschen ein bisschen
anders begegnet dieses video ist als
gemeinschaftsprojekt mit marius
angeschrien entstanden er war 24 stunden
in einem dunklen raum eingesperrt und
hat dabei untersucht wie sich der mangel
an licht auf seine psyche auswirken
ich war nun 24 stunden blind aber wie
ist das wenn man wirklich plötzlich für
immer blind wird das buch im dunkeln
sehen taucht ein in das leben eines
mannes für den das realität wurde bei
blinkt ist der sponsor des heutigen
videos gibt es unzählige hörbücher
dieser art die man in seinem alltag
parallel hören kann und seine zeit
optimal zu nutzen
linkes ist bekannt für die grandiose
zusammenfassung von büchern mit denen
man innerhalb von 15 minuten die essenz
eines gesamten buches aufsaugen kann
entweder lesen oder anhören und anhören
nach bedarf sogar ein doppelter
geschwindigkeit wenn er von der
zusammenfassung gefesselt wurde könnt
ihr nun das gesamte buch genießen als
hörbuch in voller länge auf links gibt
es unzählige bücher gefüllt mit
kostbarem wissen zu den themen
wissenschaft technologie finanzen oder
produktivität und das auf deutsch und
auf englisch und jeden monat kommen
circa 40 neue titel in 25 verschiedenen
kategorien hinzu inhaliert jetzt sieben
tage lang so viel wissen wie ihr könnt
auf linke.de / tommy noch bevor
irgendein abschnitts und baut euch
dadurch ein spannendes leben auf meine
zuschauer erhalten exklusiv 20 prozent
rabatt auf das jahres-abo linkes premium
ganz oben in der video beschreibung
blinkt ist und de / pommery wenn er mich
auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
abonniert gerne diesen kanal und hier
geht es jetzt zu marius video
[Musik]